I walk into a new blitz game playing the
GM here from Serbia check and then
playing the the bogo testing some book
lines unfortunately this is not one of
the lines that I have analyzed in detail
yet in this book I started with some
other some other lines okay but then
this still feels like I'm the fairly
normal position so doesn't I don't think
it's a big deal that I don't know it too
well who came I wonder with ease what
III yep can I go with play with III
damaging his pawn structure
mm yeah it's not not very convincing but
ok um that's also night be 60 also
Knight b6 interesting attacking c4 on b3
I have a for breaking up the pawn
structure yeah ok but I came over to
taking us bed ok but 9595
ideas to play III young if he goes an
idea for and this is interesting I have
a good post on d5 okay so he's attacking
Eve form if I take Mary maybe I just
let's just take it and now should I go
and just see six or is there some great
alternative probably not but this this
doesn't look too bad good knight on d5
enter yes
hmm how to continue i wonder if i should
play a roof like be 60 be five if it
takes rugby aid I get it back maybe
bishop on a success not a bad but
diagonal but is it be five of beef be 50
be 60 b6 totally pointless ok go here
this also attend some rogue a form at
some point if it doesn't take I mean if
he takes our play will be aid
and get down get it back quickly
if it doesn't take on v6 a fruit a for
as one move Bishop e6 activating if you
place the night somewhere I can take it
and probably just go d5 I have fun good
targets good space advantage ear of
quirky I'm not better but but it looks
like looks like a playable decent
position in instantly attacking I wonder
Bishop a six maybe possibly six
that's a good that's a good target oh
wait I know beef before i can probably
take rupee 896 mcaddie to click we go
yeah i saw that he can take the six but
I v2 well I can take it to maybe this
isn't good for me laughs maybe I should
have paid more attention to this okay
but I can't put it on d3 it's so bad
mm okay the seam look the eight maybe
nine f5 but I can play don't see it yeah
I thought just g6 and I don't know if
this is helping him so much can give
this check by over but I just move the
king I still should get to the d6 porn
Jeff
okay if I take let's take here first
there's some point in checking probably
not yet I can take here right there is
no there's no big threat coming yes yeah
no point in in trying something that
there isn't damn it just as just a draw
this position these weaknesses c6 and d4
cancel each other out basically and
actually and maybe I could have played a
bit but I was I was thinking I was um
thinking I had much less time than him
so I pretty much instantly agreed to the
draw I it's it's okay it's not it's not
like black hats anything can maybe try
something on d4 but okay he can just
Queen III enters it's a dry yeah thanks
for watching I guess it this was a
pretty pretty correct game it looked
like like pretty pretty decent chess
yeah I could take on c5 him but I didn't
want to because i thought i would give
him the default square this is what's
computer to suggested wants to take on
c5 and play c6 with them pretty clear
edge for black I'm not sure again it
wants to take ok computer doesn't like
that but I like the idea I could have
taken all I could have taken a 4 of
course at the end desk and the sir
Knight c3 if he's just blundering a 4
here oh ok
yeah now they notice not much happening
in comparison who is this guy after all
doesn't have a name he doesn't have a
name in there okay yeah good game never
the less interesting chest thanks for
watching